[Music]
my kitty
the final simple things apart over this
one listen guys have you guys been well
I've got two dear guests here as you can
see Mohammed a job and brother Musa
their common I'm looking off in the
moose fruit
okay Mohammed hello my mortalities about
this comedy job at inside the club oh
good good so actually the word yes
residence yeah well it's quite
appropriate was I actually haven't seen
this video we're gonna write when I kind
of sort of greasy and I was I really
like office is really affected by this
like in a way like over she found
something me brother sisters brother the
committee yeah my father's role both
wrong to select back in time 1400 years
to the city of Medina Saudi Arabia when
we're going to walk in the middle of the
night with your nearly made herself she
would have to walk out past the
outskirts of the city and into the wild
by herself believe it or not a group of
men actually began to see an opportunity
and women nightly to North composure
which was the government like a cult
the menu you leave her alone I still got
a centuries-old Saturday saw like a
Burberry trench or Chanel jacket get
around the woman was free and a free
woman was protected by her clan she
would have no problem speaking out
against the attacker and I don't mind
him but if the woman walking out at
night wasn't wearing a Jill bomb thing
happened to be dressed a bit more
and the menu Russia was displayed an
anti pan concern members of the
community brought in situation to profit
and like so many other social political
and familial issues that Muhammad faced
during his profit college he attended
particular matter over the gun and the
verse was revealed to the firaon the
Muslim holy book Oh prophet at me tell
your wives your daughters and the women
of the believers to drop calmness about
that Armon precludes it's better so let
me not be known as immaculate and this
is selective translation area as will
come to realize is a very specific kind
of garment which covers this very
specific type to the body there's
another part for our which says that
which hopefully she'll mention basically
the birth advises that all women
similarly so that it can't be picked out
from one another and then there was the
matter of practicality how will a view
her wondrous policy function and her
body was convicted by accomplished
publications honor
Jimmy's would in the end the early
German scholars ruled that a woman's way
of dress should be face up to
consideration over your several
functions and society of parole what we
might consider her job just as a society
specific captain's looking for okay when
was in wrong now muscles like your
historical rulings and apply them to the
modern era did you get that yes today
colleges said sounds long shooting so
that's the principle yeah so that is
saying she saying the principle okay
physical social or what you wear it's
really warrior indirect that you want oh
that's her social stairs and how this is
the norms of society okay she mentioned
those two yeah she's a investor basis so
she's saying that was back then so a
Christian was what it was collar to do
it in stages bringing that to today's
time I say no this is a different era
she's using she's saying what scholars
are doing
is making historical she's delicious
isn't clear good timing in no time
delighted in this bangle an hour okay
well is that correct is not correct
because there's love things will show a
service in the deed which I'm very
strict what I praised yeah that's if you
could excuse the same objects okay five
prayers that they are our historical
ruling unit came down at time of the
Prophet so what's going to stop us from
praying mouth is there anything stopping
uh Sabrina what's the difference in
between the like the injunctions of
prayer and injunctions of anything else
like father where is the line will be
drawn
who's gonna draw the line yeah so she
attempting to draw the line in a suit in
a place where suits maybe have personal
prevalence here preference but then she
has to be art where you gain this
information yeah this one time ago for
Iowa so now is that coming from
scholarly consensus and it comes from
you yeah if you prefer music who are you
and this is really important because a
lot of people that come and say I mean
me I would scoff in a lot here be
careful you know why because we're
saying or on the sunnah and the
salafiyyah I mean these free up key if
somebody found that said to you i me we
interpreted I not be careful because
we're looking for ransom and the
salafiyyah Indian I have so much mass as
well I wanted way a trash should be
based on customs and function customers
so what does that mean for more than
money in America today someone like me
sure it means that I have a function a
role in society a contribution that I
can make second it means that while I'm
making that contribution and living in a
society where veiling is not the custom
and where in fact if I fail it might
actually lead to harassment and wearing
what is the custom such as the dress
parenting or even yoga pants is not only
accepted what's the old water that's
what I know that bro notified to let
them go got back hi-hi nicking leg nails
it so okay well the question is where
she gave us information for some of the
information what does she say laughter
she said this what's
detrimental and she goes is because okay
because of course resonant now yeah here
or they gonna be area so that does
that's that's that's ridiculous
because what she seemed basically trying
to say I'm conscious transfer here
so for example let's say listen we're in
the neck up it's come to a point so
dangerous assisted life in danger yet
but scholars my comments a look yes it's
better when we are talking about what
she's saying it look full out basically
I have to look like you so they were she
insane is what she's wearing know what
yeah let me say that she's ready to try
before you know that click we have his
bow is what she's really saying yeah we
have to bow to the post-colonial Westin
yeah education yeah yeah and if we don't
bow to that because we're going to be
harassed otherwise then we're going to
be fearful of our harassment and
therefore for fearful of our estimate we
shouldn't practice our religion so if
tomorrow they say don't pray yeah we
should say okay the same thing applies
with president yeah dude oh yeah after
tomorrow to say don't say the shad that
don't see your Muslim yeah then the same
thing will consider your plier so
there's nothing left of Islamic yeah and
so she because the thing is she's going
to get three you know no perspective
here just me it's not just say this I
find it hard to wear it but the
commandments is clear just say that
instead of well let's see what she has
to say right yeah sure wait does that be
right after all haven't we all come to
assume that I'm a woman must bear that
very is a requirement of her faith
there's even a term that we've all come
to associate with some women failed an
Arabic term that we all have choose
whether or not we've been aware of it
chin job she goes to maybe Amin
maybe the requirement that it woman damn
is it a different part of the project so
those of you who don't know the Quran
consists of 114 chapters six thousand
plus the verses the reads
refers to how a woman should dress the
first is the birth of already
- about the seconds at the verse that
directly speaks to the process by asking
that Bay began to dress a bit more
modestly because of their role their
function in society as his wife so the
very birth is similar to the first in
that it was revealed in direct response
to adorable situations early records
show that a custom the fashion during
the pre-islamic era what for women to
wear a scarf on ahead combat trimmer so
stuff like that my friend tiny ears very
this is sorry to have to do this right
but this is she's going to come out now
and reinvent the wheel yeah we have to
be convinced of her qualifications and
her ability to have access to go Quran
so she called every lock the only one
mode machines what I don't know is that
understand me or something but Louis
isn't she lunch is nothing in Arabic it
means nothing the word she was trying to
actually pronounce you mahi MA
okay Sophie mom it's a way to say the
word yeah
no I'm not to believe you me I'm not
trying to be taking 30 years I am NOT
I'm saying if you're going to come out
and don't shine reinvent the wheel and
you are required with pronounce the word
probably oh yeah
this will just show something about your
ignorance I'm sorry yes Dignan stone it
but don't have the don't have the
courage to spread your ignorance of the
flow behind the back in the past a woman
wore a tight and fat or a bodice which
she left open before she saw before
where they explain it seems argelia
resource above 20 months right through
earring is peninsula a verse was bent
down asking that women use this scarf or
any other garment to cover the breast
and that's it
that's basically all there is in the
Quran and sir
okay honey the governor is not happy but
a lot of people that so the verse in the
Quran chapter 24 verse 31 well you have
will not be happy for mutti analogy will
be in there so let them either women
throw their Imams over that bosoms yeah
this similar hear the words came on
itself look at any other condition area
of the of the early period listen maja
tell our rules and follow for on
anything you want look at any of the
Arabic poetry yeah look at because the
generally poetry the old Arabic poetry
is it tells us what we are used to how
you use words look any of that hadith
values of the Prophet the what t mark
means a head covering that goes down
that's what it means also doesn't it
mean that you know alcohol come a
country doesn't that mean that it covers
the head you know when you out for cover
tomorrow a hundred companies in Russia
covers the mind which is yeah it's the
same word it was for but if it covers
the mind yeah
so I would use as evidence table one
saying is that it's from the head it
starts from the head near the world
itself something which sauce maybe goes
down now the question is when did it go
down to and this is where the discussion
is with the Muslim scholars some
scholars which are the minority we have
to say but still just because the
minority doesn't mean that they have a
with your opinion yeah but Hannibal let
they say goes out fully so it covers the
face as well yeah and some others say no
it goes down like this so in other words
it goes down by allows the hands in the
face to be to be shown now this is a
very well-known difference of opinion
but it starts from the head the works
tomorrow
this is lootellan advocated acid the
other thing if there's any doubt by it
would have been talked about by someone
in the bust but no doubt about
whatsoever that for the thousand four
hundred years of Islamic history and the
hundreds the most of our tens of
thousands of what hundreds of thousands
if not millions of scholars and discuss
this matter
yeah I've always confined it to this
this difference of opinion IVA is the
face in the hands are covered in it's
one of the common said no a scholar in
the history of Islam
has ever said that no player could be
covered forthwith
let me go God isn't Jennifer's point on
parked on a woman's body that he wants
to interview and in fact it might be
argument it is argue I cannot stress
enough that it is argued by many Muslims
all right so fluid or purses were left
intentionally bag it so that a woman
could choose for herself how to dress
according to her dress all right one
more relative and the progression of
having please tell me what's going in
that it's just I could it's like me I
could say and say guys loads of scholars
loads man look so many have said that
nedra can one is cool man okay that it's
not reference yes look left or they were
passionate yeah let's not target her
mother it's not a man so we're just
upset with that ignorance here not less
more or less rigid very source warming
to the variables yes for me because
always so how's that ignorance yeah so
so it's like rich wonderful she's coming
under this father starting I love you I
mean have you noted is rocking the
parameters of it if we sort of run over
Christie oh yeah or Jew or atheist or
annual because we argue against these
people they say look I love your scholar
say this a lot of us got to say that
yeah we just said it like that yeah
what's the first question they're
downright lips gonna or we scholars go
at that let me ask you a question as
well yeah at the time before Islam
before it's done would the woman go
would women go around the Kaaba topless
and make it what is it happen yes yeah
okay so this actually goes against her
initial point because she said that
there needs to be it needs to be a
societal norm it needs to be a norm in
society you need to be a custom to your
society you need to be dressing in a way
that your society is comfortable within
a full gel bar is not what the Arabs
were comfortable with at that time
oh yeah if they will get they would go
around topless and if they would go
around the car by naked how is that
society to know here you have to flavor
that goes against your pointer wearing
in jail guard in this country is more of
a societal norm then you would have been
wearing it at the time of the prophet
salaallah slow voice therefore is from
this line also can I defend isn't it
refers for that remember I did a video
at some time ago
is it the work come on actually refers
to like any tape or page that wear your
socks where is my supposed to be drunk
on my head on my hand yeah one can see
is the work itself here is that when it
was using the Arabs when they would look
at a horse and if the horse was white
and this part of his head onwards was
black they wouldn't say are oh yeah am I
so am i the word actually mean that it's
the word within itself it's actually
referring to the header head like this
so if I catch you look there's also very
funky do they like that happens and
let's turn hey John yes it's not any of
these precursors okay well this is sorry
I think this the only lesson you've ever
done I stopped any tension and I didn't
wanting it John broke this you know what
what mine is a big volunteer yeah the
word hijab had got nothing to do with
the veil anyway so stroking now what she
done is this we have come to this
country and in this country would refer
to as a hedge ah yes
okay I know why were in Arab countries
these are countries yet they were still
read to us so he got the other person
okay yeah okay now what she's done it
this is new words that's been made
yeah and she is using this argument to
say hey the Quran doesn't mission he
dunno when I you're right it doesn't
literally hijab but then we both agree
on that what her job is always made for
like Barry or something either yes yes
no what is what is it about is she
saying look the intricacy mentioned and
when I hope you've only known as little
of it what what what why is the core
fundamental belief of a Muslim togi
religious level Tony dryly its elite
believing in one God you know this is
the core fundamental belief of a Muslim
is believing in one God
sorry how many times I thought he'd
mentioned in the Quran this example like
if I'm told he does one I've ever since
I'm Muslim to speak you know all of us
again I'm trying to say that yeah I'm
saying if we want to use that ultimately
sorry how many times is Christian
mentioned in the Bible none how many
times good no no these arguments are
pure I personally feel like it's just a
personal thing for her she don't want to
wait it out something is this is shows
to me
anyone that would believe this and take
this but you know what not a face of an
invaluable class is over there if the
word hijab was used shoot probably on an
argument but the fact that the word
khimar is used yeah and just bad or the
plurals is whether she'd go to let's go
because the words came out actually
specify the location actual centrality
from the head going downward so if you
want examples use it would be more
unspecific than the what tomorrow your
retina I need to pee and you came
suddenly like honestly no one deal to
the first button if I can squeeze in
your system dragons were children for
eternal dissipation that means picture
that physical screen at Michigan that
barrier that divide that mean pigeon
hijab doesn't mean a woman spell [ __ ]
serious Peshmerga it turns out that the
Prophet first wife was what we would be
finding today as a CEO and the Mohammed
but in life to your own it's a battle on
the back of a camel which is equivalent
to a woman riding is about today in fact
one woman became famous as the general
when she led her army of men into battle
and crush a rebellion women even lovely
the babies with the profit amount so far
we bring it with your service la única
days of the week are you okay with that
cool Society the 680 it might be a huge
step forward a lot of your clothes look
okay that's it punching me I have to get
her she's seen if we go back to that
time yeah the woman actually has more at
yes Tommy please well yeah was your same
progression Robin exactly that was a
profound point that I would give it is
okay okay you know why because that's
exactly what we push out to be and
that's why the problem is we found out
that is a sentence yeah okay she has
museums in America
yeah okay now this is what we see well
means you are talks here we say look if
you wanted abolish the abuse of women by
men after the task beating but I didn't
beat this what do you do
bring something Batman made fourteen
hundred years later or last she says go
about 1,400 years ago
yeah you can tell Engelberg exactly you
know she's not implementing what I'm
saying right but you get my point if we
want to get over to beat this abuse
women etc yeah well yes we shall
implement the Quran and Sunnah this is
how we abolish this constant with our
project tell your wives your daughters
and the women of the believers to try
our parents out their garments
parenthesis a garment is a veil that
covers the entire head and the face the
neck the breasts all the way down to be
ankles and all the way to the wrists
everything on a woman's body is exposed
except for one eye because you must be
aware she every other look over here and
have must be covered in love okay she
tried saying that the people who have
the reason trusted with the
interpretation of the Quran yes and if
all the people that had been entrusted
with the interpretation of the Quran
have been met no I am okay so let's
think about even at the time of the
Prophet which women were at the fore of
interpreting clinic jurisprudence or
chronic verses in life jurisprudence
people like Aisha Roger line intellect
on the center and people like Lena
so they actually talk to these other
women who we have the I would say out of
what the majority of a heady that refer
to the hijab yeah come from these women
because a continent because of them I
got on this video effect which also
woman I think was my room I'm right a
key more are these come from Aisha then
only at that they specifically
translated these verses to mean what I'm
telling you I assure she's the one which
what these verses came he that's that
where these verses came down when the
mothers of the believers they heard
these verses yeah the other ones who not
only they knew I meant what they acted
upon it instant in season he was naked
man I'm sorry woman would actually wit
cause of their clothes and when the
words came out and run running so what
are you women or men that we're doing
this it was women that were doing Ezra
so how did they interpret the Quran they
were the women that were talking about
so what she's doing a the first problem
is that she's doing this services I
figured I was all men nervous old man
number two let's just say it's all men
for the sake of argument yeah it's not I
mean there is a considerable amount of
Islamic scholars government and consider
warm at more than any other religion
hundreds of thousands of Muslim scholars
many women never they colluded I think
of it this way they could route it
together to intentionally superimpose a
very specific type or getting on to the
verse of the Koran and get winded and
get women and you've got one of them or
not at least a community of them and who
have reputation to others
and the sacred sizes would stand up and
say you know what let's do the right
thing in terms of the verses in the
correct way in light of the army and
this is this is actually a conspiracy
what's him are as you said it means from
the top to the bottom so he said okay I
mean the whole way there's no doubt
about that
the only difference is it one eye is it
make us is it not just in terms of you
that is one is okay you don't need to
say time ups but I'm you're saying that
lease is within the sort of discussion
here what you say is not over the sort
of discussion with Islam is not
conforming to the social norms see fools
are cops we get this today when it is a
planet one did she mention wants color
you mentioned price phonetically review
one one one one will grow reference even
when she refers to Quran Jaden reference
of oculus are big political college is
welcome this year Amen sister
any believer that watches this and sees
it as something that affects them
I'm sorry desires there's nothing
nothing nothing zero so guys
[Laughter]
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo shoo-shoo hey give
me one I'm sorry
subscribe